pour eux plus près de nous l'hiver 54 à
lui été très très rude
il y aura demain quarante ans un prêtre
inconnus alors l'abbé pierre lancé sur
les ondes de radio luxembourg un appel à
la solidarité en faveur des sans logis
problème hélas toujours d'actualité
quatre décennies après very les
régulateurs de vitesse les dix lignes
mes amis au secours etc mais sans aucune
préparation j'ai pas pris une demi-heure
à main réfléchir c'est venu comme ça
parce que c'était convives en main on ne
pouvait plus tant qu'il restera une
famille l'objet comme des cochons les
combats devrait être le même
et on pourrait presque dire paradoxal -
y en a plus on est coupable parce que
quand il y en avait la moitié des
français très longtemps mais plus on
approche d'un petit nombre
plus c'est possible d'en sortir
maintenant oui il n'ya plus que neuf sur
plan dans ces conditions si
véritablement la volonté politique est
politique
d'abord dans l'opinion publique parce
que dieu merci en démocratie et en
démocratie les les élus les ministes les
candidats ils font ce que veut le plus
grand nombre or comme heureusement en
france
c'est par le plus grand nord qui est
dans la misère et dans le fait plus pas
de ceux qui sont dans la misère
ils font pas un poids électoral
important